on this Thanksgiving is appropriate we
talk about food and other things that we
take in our bodies and we want to
welcome Michael Fomento who's the author
of bio evolution how biotechnology is
changing our world good morning thanks
for joining us good morning thank you
what's the message from this book the
message is that biotechnology is the
most exciting science going out there
that's why I chose to write about this
topic and that in the next few years or
shall we say right now it's change it's
going to change absolutely everything in
our lives
what is biotechnology everybody has
their own definition I don't have a
monopoly on that but the one I use is
either the selective use of a gene or
genes or doing something to in some way
again specifically and intentionally
interact with the genome quote
biotechnology won't bring utopia there
will be no dawning of the Age of
Aquarius biotechnology won't stop all
pain physical or psychological it won't
be the answer to every medical problem
we know today and it will not and it
will have to deal with some we don't
know about yet it can eventually solve
all the world's foods food problems but
it won't solve all the environmental
problems healthy lifespans will be
extended dramatically but if it's
immortality you seek then seek elsewhere
what biotechnology does offer is a tool
that can make the planet unimaginative
now that's a tall order yes and yet you
see in there that there I'm not
promising pie on the sky I am actually
by nature something of a pessimist then
definitely [ __ ] nature a skeptic I
have made my reputation as a skeptic so
when I say that the miracles in this
book and this book is filled with what
could be called miracles are going to
come to fruition and more than that most
of them will come to fruition in the
next five to ten years then coming from
a skeptic such as myself you'd better
believe it it's going to happen okay
let's take two things first of all food
how can
solve the world's food problems well we
had something called the Green
Revolution which was absolutely terrific
we had people like Paul Ehrlich saying
that millions and millions of people
would starve to death because the
population would outstrip the food
supply because of the Green Revolution
the food supply it has continued to
provide more and more calories per
person throughout the world not just in
the United States what is very obvious
but the Green Revolution unfortunately
also had to rely on things like far more
fertilizer far more chemicals of all
sorts far more irrigation which causes
problems and there's only so much water
to irrigate with biotech will take care
of all of that will need less irrigation
will need less water to grow these crops
will be able to grow crops in salty
water will be able to grow crops with
far fewer inputs such as fertilizers and
pesticides and will simply be able to
grow more crops in less area period
through again taking maybe a single gene
or a few genes and taking them out of
one organism and putting them into
another perhaps four times as many crops
in per acre as we can now our phone
lines are open we welcome your comments
you can also send us an email at journal
at c-span org our guest is Michael
fermenter who is out with his new book
on biotechnology the other aspect
dealing with medicine and you say that
in the 1990s 13% of all new medicines
came from biotechnology right and more
important the trend line is going up we
will eventually get to a point again
before too long we're all medicine is in
some way
biotechnology related a few examples
there was a great example just a couple
of weeks ago in the news about so-called
liquid or so-called Drano for the
arteries now this again this is truly a
miracle drug they found that just five
injections of a protein cleared out four
percent of the plaque in the
participants arteries four percent of
the plaque and moreover there's no
reason to think there was more
injections they couldn't clear out more
but four percent is incredible it would
take a statin drug eighteen months to
accomplish the same thing in short this
dry
could lead because it can prevent
atherosclerosis which is one of the
biggest killers in the United States and
art disease is the biggest killer this
drug could save literally hundreds of
thousands of American lives alone each
year and this drug is biotech it was
discovered 25 years ago in northern
Italian men that they had a special
protein that gave them a certain type of
cholesterol that greatly lowered their
risk of heart disease well 25 years ago
it was a nice discovery but they
couldn't do anything with it but then
biotech came along gene splicing
specifically came along and they were
able to take this protein and splice it
into bacteria and grow as much as they
wanted that's the future of medicine for
somebody who made just tuned in may be
watching the turkey tips on the other
morning programs why should they care
about this why is it important it's
important in any way you can think of
it's important in terms of for example
human health again one when we think of
one biotech drug helping to prevent
hundreds of thousands of premature
deaths per year in the United States
alone when you think of just a few
different types of biotech plants that
are already well underway as far as
being developed that will save tens of
millions of lives maybe hundreds of
millions by preventing malnutrition and
blindness and what-have-you through the
world when you think of something called
bioremediation
which means the use of microorganisms or
other or plants or what-have-you
to clean up toxic waste dumps in an
environmentally friendly and cheap way
when you look at just those few areas of
biotech again you see how this is going
to cause absolutely dramatic drastic and
very good changes for the world some
background on our guest Michael fomento
who's the author of this book bio
evolution how biotechnology is changing
our world he began his career working
for congressman Dan crane back in the
1980s he's a graduate of the University
of North Carolina where he earned his
undergraduate degree and then on to the
University of Illinois served in the US
Army is a former fellow at the American
prai's institute used to write for the
washington times and also for the Rocky
Mountain News and our first call is from
Philadelphia good morning good morning I
had a question as to how you felt about
stem-cell research as to whether or not
you felt this fell into this area and my
comments before you comment on it would
be if certain people in the government
are so pro-life and why are they against
dem cell research
whenever it could prolong people's lives
in essence being pro-life through
medical advances and advances in farming
to feed the starving people around the
world Thank You caller unfortunately
there's a lot of Mythology concerning
stem-cell research and the first thing
you need to understand is there are two
completely different paths two
completely different types of stem cells
you are talking about what are called
embryonic stem cells and these are made
by growing human embryos and literally
ripping them apart in order to get the
stem cells from them people have ethical
problems with that because whether or
not you believe that this is a very
early abortion as some people do there's
no doubt that in embryos human life it's
not a chicken it's not a monkey it's a
human it is human
so people have ethical problems with
that and we all need to be concerned
with other people's ethical problems
whether we believe that or not the other
problem is embryonic research does in
fact lead to cloning research there's no
getting around it that it's the very
first step towards human cloning you can
stop at some point if you wish but the
research will lead in that direction
that's why people have problems with
embryonic stem cell research but there's
something called adult stem cells now
these have already been used
therapeutically since the 1980s if
you've ever heard of a bone-marrow
transplant or an umbilical cord
transplant what they're really
transplanting are the stem cells so this
has already been used in humans the
embryonic
is only now getting into rodent studies
the adult stem cells furthermore they're
finding more and more uses for these
things such that while it used to
believe
be believed that only embryonic cells
potentially could become every type of
tissue in the human body
where stem cells were more limited they
could become lots of types but they were
more limited it's now being found that
stem cells are found throughout the body
so that even if they are limited
somewhat in what they can become if
they're found throughout the body maybe
we don't need one-size-fits-all
moreover three different sets of
researchers have found that perhaps a
single type of stem cell adult stem cell
mind you can in fact become all types of
cells in the body so I argue in my book
we don't need the embryonic and we don't
need all that ethical baggage that comes
with the embryonic the stem the adults
themselves will work other books by our
guest Michael Fomento include science
under siege the myth of heterosexual
AIDS and also the that of the land the
obesity epidemic and how overweight
Americans can help themselves
Albuquerque New Mexico next for our
guest good morning good morning happy
Thanksgiving Mandy you too hey yeah I'd
like your guests there to also mention
the fact that a lot of countries a lot
of people in the world refuse to eat our
bio text you know just because you can
do something doesn't necessarily mean
you should you know we're getting so
arrogant that we think we can recreate
things that God has created
that's foolish I think thanks for the
so is the father of with it still
account of he was recruited while in
jail I don't have a go to work on
plastics and chemicals your response
really I'd rather stick to biotechnology
but the fact is this lady is completely
wrong silicone implants were invented by
Americans they were first used in the
United States in the 1960s they have
absolutely nothing to do with the Nazis
this is an urban legend page 125 of your
book old people are living to be
somewhat older due to a host of factors
especially better health care for
seniors and better nutrition still none
of this affects what's called the
natural human lifespan that is more and
more of us are getting closer to the
maximum and more importantly we're
getting there in better shape yet we're
repeatedly told that our natural
lifespan or outside limit of longevity
for humans is fixed at about 120 years
or is it it's not I just spoke of one
urban legend another urban legend is
that people can only live to be about
120 and then we there's something built
into us that makes us drop over dead
that I quote doctor in there saying that
this is just pulled out of thin air
based on the fact that very few people
in the world have in fact lived past 120
moreover biotech could break through
even if this word natural barrier
biotech could and will break through
this already by my count there are eight
biotech gene therapies alone they could
do so now by that I mean simply
basically flipping on a gene flipping
off a gene or maybe adding in more genes
that these have already been shown in
rodent experiments and and lower
life-forms that age in very much the
same way that humans do and they've made
these creatures live to be 50 30% longer
50% longer to live even longer than that
so if the average American now is dying
the average 40 year old can expect about
40 more years now they can really many
of us many of the people watching the
show I'm telling you right now are going
to live well past 120 in fact well past
150 and most importantly they the period
before they become decrepit before they
has to be in a wheelchair or in a
nursing home and or what have you
well likewise be extended well into
maybe 140 150 years or even more
Columbus Ohio good morning hello thank
you for c---span first of all I'd I'd
like to recommend and that relief book
nature versus nurture to anybody was
wanting to familiarize themselves with
DNA genetics but I wanted to ask mr.
Smith about I'm reading a book right now
by Edwin black war against week.this
about eugenics and in it he says that we
should be worrying about the patches
patenting of genes that that's almost on
the same line of thought as what caused
the horror of eugenics thank you you
have to understand that throughout
history people have been trying to
improve everything about them whether
it's their livestock whether it's their
crops an earlier caller talked about how
this is playing God I think with you
know the expression always pops up by
trying to alter the things around us
well the fact is for example with crops
and with animals
we've been altering their genomes for
five thousand years now through
traditional crossbreeding biotech is
simply an improvement upon that well
with eugenics it's only natural that
people are going to want to their
children to be somewhat smarter that
they're going to want them to be
improved in any way and guess what
they're already doing it but right now
it tends to favor rich people because
they can put their kids to the best high
schools private schools college
if in fact we ever use gene-splicing
gene therapy to make our kids say
smarter this will hardly be anything new
and more than that the worst thing about
eugenics was not the the idea of simply
trying to improve the human race there
were the excesses of eugenics as we saw
in the the Nazi era was bait was
sterilizing and killing off the weak the
so-called inferior if we ever see any
kind of eugenics with biotech it would
not involve killing off or sterilizing
anybody our guest is Michael Fomento our
topic biotechnology the book bio
evolution how biotechnology is changing
our world
Indianapolis good morning yes thanks for
the opportunity for calling in I think
we've kind of gotten off track I just
wanted to get back to the environmental
implications of altering crops and
different types of aspects of how the
human body reacts to those changes as
well when we change the crop from its
original lifespan and or original
intention in nature because I believe
nature has cycles and sometimes crops
aren't meant to go beyond an extended
period of time I understand with a food
and health crisis trying to feed those
who can't and aren't possible are not in
aren't able to grow crops in a region
where they may have been struck by a
natural disaster but at some point in
time Nature has a way of balancing it
out and when we start messing with the
balance do you think there's some
implications in the future that may
cause us to have some unforeseen
problems that we hadn't really thought
of just because of a simple tampering
with the lifespan of a crop and thank
you color it's important to keep in mind
that virtually nothing we eat now that
does not have the word wild in it is as
it originally was so okay let's grant
the Euell Gibbons is wild a curry nuts
we're always that way but on the other
hand
now today's Thanksgiving what about
turkeys if you've ever seen a live
Turkey as bread in a farm versus a wild
turkey you know there is an incredible
difference everything else we eat let's
say we have corn today for Thanksgiving
there is no such thing as wild corn corn
was invented 5000 years ago by Mexican
Americans by combining several types of
wild grasses now that gave them a corn
that looks at very tiny ear such as you
might get say in Chinese food then in
the 1920s and 1930s American scientists
developed this corn even more to give us
the nice large sweet ears that we have
today
tomatoes used to be about the size of
golf balls and about the same color as
golf balls as well everything we eat
pretty much has already been genetically
modified the diferences biotech allows
it to be done scientifically quickly and
with the oversight of the FDA the USDA
and the EPA they just this side note
from today's New York Times this is a
poultry distributor in Harlem New York
and carrying on a tradition that began
80 years ago providing live turkeys
fresh guaranteed for Thanksgiving next
call is from Paige springs Arizona good
morning good morning thank you for
taking my call on the little nervous
this morning I've noticed that in
watching the cloning history that of
Dolly etc that I if I'm not mistaken it
takes the uses of the uterus to to make
the cloning happen and I've also noticed
that it's always the men that seem to
have the biggest problem with the
cloning and is it true women can clone
women and there would be no more use of
procreation in our normal form if women
could do this and is that why men are so
afraid of it you call her it is true
there is a method of cloning
obviously it's not in use yet it's a
potential method it's called
parthenogenesis and you could
theoretically create women from women
there would be identical copies of their
mothers this is something that I don't
think it's a particularly good thing and
I think that women as well as men share
my concern I don't think this is a male
concern we'll leave it at that
from page 251 getting more vitamins into
foods we enjoy a major goal of biotech
engineers as it happens
those who pop vitamin supplements also
are those likely to eat well while
unfortunately non poppers tend to eat
more junk and in essence what you say in
this chapter on foods that taste too
good to be healthy is the influence of
vitamins in products like milk other
dairy items that normally would not be
there and the difference between what we
have in this country with vitamin D
installed and/or being incorporated into
the milk versus those in third world
nations that drink it straight from the
cow exactly so all countries have or had
at one point vitamin deficiencies in the
United States with vitamin D
deficiencies we had iodine deficiencies
we had folic acid deficiencies so what
do we do well we add a vitamin D to milk
we've added folic acid to bread quite
recently and we've added iodine to salt
now in an industrialized country like
the u.s. you can do that and you can do
that cheaply but there are terrible far
worse vitamin deficiencies in
underdeveloped countries for example
vitamin A iron and zinc are the big
three really because of the lack of
vitamin C or vitamin A in rice which is
a staple crop throughout much of the
world a couple of million people die
every year it is the leading cause of
childhood blindness the fact that
there's no vitamin A in rice biotech is
changing that even as we speak
because researchers have created
something called golden rice where they
have taken genes out of all things the
daffodil flower which has vitamin A in
it and they've inserted those genes into
the rice
so now when people eat rice they get the
vitamin A they need maybe not all they
need but there are gonna be other ways
of getting the vitamin A as well
moreover these same researchers took
this rice which has iron in it but it's
not viable a bit bioavailable in other
words our bodies can't break it down and
use it they added another gene to make
that iron in the rice bioavailable so
they actually did more to the rice but
the point is made that they have now
taken with one staple crop they've taken
it it had two great malnutrition
problems vitamin A and iron and they
have changed that through biotechnology
and it's already been done this is not
the work of the future this is the work
of his a here and now Washington Post
reporting this morning from a new United
Nations report on hunger in America and
around the world saying it is increasing
nation across the globe the number of
hungry people in the world increasing
during the last half of the 1990s by 18
million worldwide to a total of 842
million people reversing the steady drop
over the past three decades according to
a new study by a UN agency more than one
in seven people in the world endure
chronic hunger which is measured by a
daily intake of less than 1,700 calories
and a lack of access to safe and
nutritious food the vast majority about
seven hundred ninety eight million lived
in poor developing countries about 10
million reside in the world's wealthiest
industrialized nations next call is from
Oakland California good morning yeah
good morning um I'm reminded of a
article I written Mother Jones a couple
years ago regarding um genetically
modified salmon in British Columbia and
this article mentions that if one of
those modified Salmons
jumps out of the fish farm in Canada it
can contaminate the entire natural
species of salmon in the Pacific
Northwest now how you can explain that
to the Native Americans well the first
thing I'd explain is than anything you
read and Mother Jones is going to be
anti biotechnology that's their
viewpoint and they're never going to
stray from it no matter how many lives
it will save Mother Jones isn't
concerned about the starving countries
in Africa it's concerned about its
American readership as
this particular salmon goes these salmon
first of all are sterilized they cannot
breed second of all they're held in
controlled pens where theoretically yes
one could escape hey we've all seen
Jurassic Park after all but this is
another protection finally these salmon
really are for the most part inferior as
far as survival the only trait they have
that makes them superior is that they
grow to market size about three times
faster than an ordinary salmon they
don't actually grow bigger ultimately
they just get to full size somewhat
larger that means that they can be
brought to market more quickly they can
be brought to market more cheaply and
ultimately the same techniques can be
used not just in salmon which is pretty
much a you know a first-world type fish
but it can be used in fish throughout
the world to feed the starving millions
of people that we just heard about
and of course fish is an extremely
wonderful high-protein food a related
email from this viewer who says quite
some time ago National Public Radio
talked about the problem of the same
antibiotics being used in livestock as
it is as administer to people the
problem here is that when people eat
enough of this they develop a tolerance
for or even an immunity to that said
antibiotic this then creates problems in
treating people for medical conditions
for which a shared antibiotic is the
treatment correct or not well the jury's
actually still out on that but insofar
as it has nothing nothing really to do
with biotechnology I really rather not
go into it next call is from Trenton
Florida good morning yes good morning I
just want to preface this that I'm all
for biotechnology advances but I just
had a couple of small questions I don't
know how to really word it all together
but I wondered with all the money that's
poured into research do you think we get
the right bang for the buck as it were
and and is it is that getting to be too
costly to to where we can't afford the
products that we're developing that's a
really good question because some of
these new biotech
drugs while they are miraculous there's
really no other word for it in that
sense of course I don't mean a gift from
God but I mean something that's just an
absolute leap beyond anything we've had
before we're getting drugs that treat
diseases that literally all a doctor
before could do was give you an aspirin
and say you know I sympathize with you
we're getting these drugs but some of
them are extremely expensive to make a
pill can literally cost just a few cents
to make if it's combinatorial chemistry
even though they might sell it for three
bucks it cost three cents to make some
of these biotech drugs actually for a
month's supply costs several thousand
dollars to make for that month supply
but the biotech industry is working on
making these in much cheaper factories
if you will the current factories are
and I've discussed this earlier splicing
a gene into bacteria and growing them in
bacteria or splicing them into mammalian
cells usually from hamsters or putting
them in yeast these are all fairly
expensive techniques but already one
company now is splicing proteins into
corn how much does it cost to grow this
special corn about what it costs to grow
sweet corn they're also working at
splicing these same genes into all sorts
of other crops those with large amounts
of protein in them naturally because
we're talking protein drugs here they're
looking at flight at splicing them into
milk in which you wouldn't actually
drink the milk
but the proteins would be extracted from
the milk again at perhaps pennies per
dose and then finally we're working on
putting these proteins into eggs where
one chicken lays up on average about an
egg a day that is absolutely packed with
protein one chicken perhaps in half a
year could supply all of the biotech
medicine needed for all the sufferers of
a single disease on planet Earth so
ultimately while some of these drugs are
horribly expensive we're going to make
them to a point where they're incredible
shape if you want to get more
information on the concepts behind the
book you can log on to bio evolution org
or else Furman TOCOM after our guest
Michael fomento both of these websites
by the way are available by simply
linking on to c-span org this email from
Sean and Kentucky wants to know mr.
Fomento if you could detail wetware a
sci-fi concept involving technology
adapted to biology such as modifying
eyesight strength etc well a lot of
these things are actually not being done
through biotechnology at all and I think
that's really reassuring usually when
you hear of these these really fanciful
sorts of things such as super soldiers
or things like this I explain to people
you're not going to get that through
biotechnology because all biotechnology
really involves is moving genes around
or as I said just maybe designing a drug
to interact with the genome and so for
example maybe you can take a gene from a
naturally very strong person and get
that into an embryo or into the germline
of somebody who would naturally be weak
and you'll get a somewhat stronger
person but that's all you're gonna get
if you really want say a super soldier
or you know Six Million Dollar Man
you're gonna have to do it exactly the
way they did it with the Six Million
Dollar Man you're gonna have to go the
bionics route and that truly will give
you you know things such as we see in
the Terminator movies but that's that
biotech that's bionics back to your
calls New Orleans good morning welcome
to the program good morning first of all
I'd like to say your method of using
emails for stating good points is
excellent you should've wore that that's
a great new idea for the guests I want
to ask the question about human growth
hormone which is something in the health
food circles and on infomercials now is
there any legitimacy to that at all
whatsoever well human growth hormone is
in fact all biotech in this country and
the reason is they originally extracted
it from the pituitary glands of human
cadavers and it was in fact a wonderful
drug because for example
it allowed people who are doomed to be
Dwarfs little children doomed ovide orfs
to grow to be more or less normal-sized
it's also had applications in other
therapeutic areas such as AIDS but then
it was discovered that there was
something horrible coming out of this
cadaverous human growth hormone Yakko
crux failed disease the disease it's
like mad cow syndrome but it's natural
it literally it turns your brain into
Swiss cheese and it was starting to kill
people for right at that time when they
discovered that the biotech industry
came up with gene-spliced
recombinant human growth hormone and so
now all the human growth hormone in the
United States is 100% safe so I'm glad
you brought up that point
it shows what biotech is doing for us
now your but that wasn't exactly your
question your question is I think as I
understand it is there potential for
abuse and it's really hard to say
because so often something that starts
out as purely therapeutic can start to
be used for something that is extra
therapeutic steroids originally were
purely therapeutic and for the most part
they still are steroids are helping to
keep a lot of AIDS victims alive
I've used steroids when I've had say a
shoulder pull to help me out there but
steroids as we know are also being
abused in athletics human growth hormone
was originally used to treat dwarfism
now some parents are trying to use it to
turn a child who would ordinarily grow
to me be maybe 5 foot 10 5 foot 11 and
try to get a kid who might be six foot
three six foot five and a lot of people
think that's wrong but I have mixed
feelings about it myself but you really
can't draw a bright lines like that I'm
afraid it's going to happen
Crawford Colorado good morning good
morning I am I would like to comment on
the stem cell research embryonic I was
recently blessed with a granddaughter
they took the blood from the umbilical
cord
froze it and it's my understanding that
this down the road if when they allow
new stem cell research it might be used
to help my son who's a quadriplegic also
I would like you to comment on the
European Union just approving funding
for stem cell research the gentleman
actually has it backwards although we
used the term adult stem cell to
differentiate from embryonic stem cells
the term adult stem cell is a bit of a
misnomer it includes the stem cells from
umbilical cords and from placentas which
obviously are not adults but these are
not from embryonic cells that's the
point umbilical cord cells are already
being used therapeutically this is not a
thing of the future using them to treat
diseases such as leukemia or spinal cord
problems or this or that that is
something of the future the near future
mind you because it is an advanced
testing so he actually made my point for
me
we don't need the embryonic the adult
stem cells including those pulled from
non adults will in fact do the trick for
us let me follow up on the issue of stem
cell because you lie is er oniy he was
the head of the National Institutes of
Health was interviewed by The Associated
Press yesterday and in essence he was
asked about the lines that the president
that the stem cell lines that the
president authorized in the initial
research and he is saying that if he
feels that these cell lines are stunting
research he would be the first to go to
the president to say they need more in
order to do a thorough investigative
look into the role that stem cell can
play in the future can you explain or
elaborate what what he would need well
first of all unfortunately nobody knows
exactly how many lie embryonic stem cell
lines that are out there um they're
still investigating because they're
literally all over the world we don't
know exactly for example what China has
but we know that China is
is very far along in experimenting in
this area China is not the most open
country in the world as we know it also
needs to be pointed out that you don't
need any fixed number of embryonic stem
cell lines
assuming you feel a need to have
embryonic stem cells at all which I
don't so we don't necessarily
necessarily need the sixty-two that the
president was originally told we have we
really theoretically could get by with a
single good embryonic stem cell line
assuming again we even need embryonic
stem cells Sturbridge Massachusetts good
morning we're welcome we're glad to have
you got a feeling you're really actually
a lobbyist for Monsanto
first of all one the main thing that
saved the small farmer in this country
has been organic food the Europeans do
not want our alternative food won't even
bother stuff and finally sir the biggest
threat to mankind in the next hundred
years is over population in particularly
in the industrialized area mainly
America we are three percent of the
world population we use a lot more than
25 percent of all the resources on earth
our problem is not saving people in
industrialized world our problem is
trying to save the environment caller
what's your background on this issue I'm
just a little odd about it there's a
population connection
several organizations are trying to make
the cut though this country
unfortunately realized that the
overpopulation problem in the area that
you live in there's been a book written
talking about the problems in the
Greater Washington area because you're
running out of land you're running out
of farmland to build houses on and the
road situation and the what it's doing
to smog and all these other areas it's
population problem which is which we're
not dealing with thank you for the
comment and keep listening to us on
satellite radio services michael fomento
so you have a right to your opinion
it just so happens your opinions are
completely wrong to extrapolate from
what I to perceive as a something of an
overcrowding problem in the DC area to
the world or to the United States just
doesn't work you have to use statistics
and the statistics from the United
Nations show that the world's population
is set to peak out at about 2050 at
about 9 billion people we've already got
6.3 billion so we're not going to grow a
whole lot before we peak guess what
happens after 2050 the world's
population starts to go into decline
so overpopulation simply is not the
great problem we've been told but to the
extent that we need more food and we're
going to need more food for those 2.7
billion people
biotech can easily provide it in fact
we've got other ways of providing it as
well you're talking about building
houses on farmland the reason we're able
to do that is because every year in this
country we need less and less farmland
why because of things like biotech but
other techniques as well we keep growing
more and more crops on the same amount
of land we need less farmland somebody
might as well use it
the houses are using it encounter books
is the publisher of bio evolution how
biotechnology is changing our world our
guest is Michael Fomento our next call
is New York City can you explain what
how it works between business and
politics that prevents biotechs
engineered foods from being labelled
thus preventing consumers from having a
choice it's not so much politicians it's
the FDA which has decided that food does
not need to be labeled in this country
as biotech and the reason is quite
simple the FDA says what we can only put
so much on a label now mind you and a
lot of countries they don't use food
labels at all we have actually a fairly
large one depending on the size of your
package the label may be
half the package already but the FDA
says look what goes on a label is what
the consumer really needs to know for
the consumers health there's no room for
extraneous stuff and so for example if
there are people who would like it to be
on the label whether this food was
hand-picked or machine baked the FDA
says no it doesn't affect the food it
doesn't go on the label there are people
who want on the label whether this
potato was grown in Idaho or somewhere
else the FDA says no it doesn't affect
the food whether it was grown in Idaho
or somewhere else likewise the FDA says
organic food has gone through a much
more rigorous process of approval than
non-organic food again it is approved
organics I'm sorry biotech food it has
to be approved by the FDA the EPA and
the USDA before it makes it onto the
market organic food on the other hand
that we're told is so very safe does not
necessarily need approval from anybody
you make a new organic food to the old
crossbreeding methods and you can bring
it right onto the market and if it makes
people sick it makes people sick but hey
that's the way the system is this email
from a viewer in Colorado would you care
to comment on the political issue of
environmentalists who so vigorously
opposed measures such as those you have
written about that would save many human
lives especially in the third world for
example there are people refusing to
allow genetically modified wheat to go
to Africa where it is desperately needed
is this viewer accurate it's actually
genetically modified corn but the point
is the same what has happened is last
year Africa was severely threatened by
out-and-out starvation now mind you
Africa continues to have a severe
malnutrition problem but they were
threatened without an out starvation
with literally hundreds of thousands of
deaths the United States sent over
biotech corn it had one gene put into it
that made
slightly different from the corn that
these Africans have always been eating
it is exactly the same corn that the
United that has been used in the United
States grown in the United States and
eaten here since 1996 so we were not
using Africans as guinea pigs as was
claimed we were giving them the food
that we were eating but we had extra
supplies and we were trying to be
generous and help along come the green
groups and they say no go
this is biotech we can't have biotech
food in Africa and if that means
literally millions of people starving to
death so--but the African originally the
African governments wanted the food and
then they said oh no no we have to keep
it in the warehouses because someday we
might want to export to Europe we don't
yet but we might want to and if we do
and any of this corn gets out it could
get in with our not in biotech corn and
Europe will refuse to import any of our
food now what was the action of the
starving African people god bless them
they broke into the warehouses and they
took the corn and they fed their
families anyway next call Surry Virginia
for Michael Fomento good morning good
morning I had kind of a dual-purpose
question when they cloned firstly
genetically spliced spliced a gene into
a cow that produced milk that had a drug
in it that was good for cystic fibrosis
I can't think of the name of the drug
then they cloned the cow because they
realize that if they tried to breed her
back to get offspring it would be just a
certain number by cloning they could get
it this way you could get a lot of cows
that would produce or be able to give
the milk with this certain drug in it it
was good for cystic fibrosis I went to
one of the universities spoke with the
department chief of Dairy Science
they said asked him about this thinking
that maybe it would be a good way to
help a lot of industries the drug
industry the dairy industry the dairy
farmers clone a lot of cows and certain
farmer could produce milk for this they
said they weren't interested and to up
their hands and I think it's because of
artificial insemination because this
ruined the dairy of breeding end of it I
had been a superintendent of dairy
cattle at the fair and I had a one man
to tell me he just came to the fair for
his children he said previous years
before artificial insemination he'd been
able to sell 20 Bulls calves this ended
it I guess my question is why is there
so much resistance I noticed in Europe
resistance towards any improvement okay
thank you
well first it's important to point out
that artificial insemination is really
in old technologies it's not
biotechnology and that the entire cattle
industry now relies on artificial
insemination they extract the the semen
from the bull and they use that to
impregnate essentially all all the cows
and some cows I guess still go the
old-fashioned means not biotech the rest
of what you talked about is biotech many
types of animals are in fact being gene
spice they're putting in a gene thing so
that in their milk they will produce a
therapeutic protein for example the
original cloned animal Dolly the sheep
was not cloned so that some company in
Scotland could say hey we cloned the
first mammal look at us
Dolly was cloned because she was to
carry in her milk a gene so that her
milk could be extracted and used to
create human clotting factor but this
milk can be used for any number of other
diseases
such as the one you named cystic
fibrosis which is a horrible disease but
you name it basically any protein
therapeutic protein we want can
theoretically be produced in the milk of
cows sheep goats pigs it's already being
done in fact it's just not none of it's
yet FDA approved so this is a wonderful
technology and it is being resisted it
really not so much generally in this
area Greenpeace knows to keep its mouth
shut because this is a technology that's
going to aid the first world and
Greenpeace is a little bit more shy
about that they're willing to let people
die by the millions in the third world
they're a little bit more hesitant to do
so in the first world that said there
you still see a bit of resistance here
because you hear things tossed around
that that just don't make any sense the
sound good like oh you're playing God
because you're cloning or because you're
inserting this human single human gene
or the single gene into an animal know
if okay fine if you want to say that it
is unnatural that we stop people from
dying from horrible diseases like cystic
fibrosis I'm all for you biotech is
unnatural but that's as far as I'll go
Montero California thanks for waiting oh
sure thanks for letting me on I do have
a couple questions one caller previously
made reference to Monsanto and I am
curious if your speaker has any
financial relationship with Monsanto who
receives any support or from other
similar firms but that's not my main
question well answer that and then come
back to your next point okay any
connection Monsanto is in fact a big
supporter of mine in the sense of they
have bought up some of the books as have
a lot of different companies because the
book does say good things about manse at
Monsanto so it makes perfect sense that
they would do that yeah well then at
what point are you a scientist searching
for truth now what point of us salesmen
are pitchman for Monsanto on their
products because that's what my question
is my my
concern is the idea of Monsanto or any
other corporation owning a patent on
genes you mentioned with the Golden Rice
for instance you know the people in
these third-world countries have grown
rice for centuries and centuries of
centuries and nobody owns a patent on it
they want to grow rice so they want to
experiment with rice they can do it on
their own and they don't have any
corporate masters they have to pay for
if Monsanto starts putting out golden
rice or they use other products whether
they have one generation where they have
sterile products so people have to buy
the seeds every year from Monsanto or
similarly when Monsanto has their
Roundup Ready products where they sell
seeds that will grow into plants that
are able to accept roundup one of
Monsanto's pesticides and which will
then make the farmers dependent on those
kind of seeds dependent on using that
pesticide and so I think it establishes
a dependence that really doesn't free
the third world up from hunger but
effects makes them taking products that
were their own and making making the
growing products that belong to a
distant corporation on their own land
actually your argument backfires on you
you know you talk about products of
their own I talked about a product of
their own it's called plain old white
rice that has been a staple crop
throughout much of the third world for
thousands and thousands of years I
talked about how it contained no vitamin
A no usable iron and that people
millions of people died and went blind
because of this I talked about how a
research team put the using gene
transfer technology was able to create
Golden Rice that solve that problem for
these people but and now this is the
little tiny pointer in which you're
right at that point the research team
ran into a problem there were literally
hundreds of patents out there that
theoretically could have prevented
Golden Rice from going past the
development stage and some were in fact
owned by Monsanto
what did Monsanto do it donated the
patents in fact every single patent of
these hundreds that were needed by this
research team were donated by the same
means the thus agendas the the Bayer
CropScience ists the Dow AgroSciences
all these multinationals that everybody
loves to hate all these patents were
donated these companies are also working
on crops that can't possibly bring them
a single penny but they're doing it to
help out in the third world now you may
say well they're only doing it because
it's good publicity you know personally
I couldn't give a darn whether it's good
publicity
I like seeing people's life saved I like
seeing people not going blind I like the
idea that people in Africa may Sunday
achieve the same standard of living that
we're achieving and if Monsanto wants to
spend its hard-earned money its
stockholders money in helping to develop
these crops bringing scientists over
from Africa to study at Monsanto and
then go back to Africa if Monsanto sees
that it has some sort of gain in there
then God bless Monsanto and I'm all for
it and they don't have to pay me to say
something like that
at 4:30 Eastern Time 1:30 for those of
you in the West Coast a discussion that
took place at Boston University on the
topic of human cloning part of our
afternoon schedule here on c-span next
is a call from Vista California good
morning good morning I'm I was very glad
to hear mr. Clemente oh uh explain that
golden rice situation because I heard
about that as well but I and I'm so glad
that Monsanto gave out the patent and
and allowed that to happen and I just
hope that the golden rice can get
quickly into the third world and I do
have one concern about a monsanto
product and that is that Roundup Ready
plant I used to live in the San Joaquin
Valley you know with the pesticides and
all the rest and you know I'm generally
a great supporter of biotech but when it
comes to the herbicide resistant plants
I've seen the way my farmer friends used
herbicides and if they could use more to
kill weeds they would and if they have a
plant that's resistant to it what I'm
afraid is that these that they'll
overuse the roundup that these crops
that in the past would have died before
they could have come to our
Table would instead be like saturated
with the roundup material and with these
other herbicides that the plants are now
resistant to but the weeds aren't thanks
for the comment caller with about a
minute left we'll take one more from
Houston Texas good morning thank you
very much how did Steve and happy turkey
day three things really quickly number
one this is one of many things that's
going on if we're gonna have a shortage
of anything isn't it going to be a
scientist number two how important is it
for us to preserve old species old seeds
I know you aren't Canadians or all these
number three and this is way down the
line way out there but if anybody is
concerned about limits to growth how
many square miles are there on the moon
how many are there on Mars and
agricultural concerns of
cross-contamination greenhouses on the
moon that battle will eliminate that
problem there's a lot there can you
summarize quickly no we don't need
greenhouses on the moon we can do
everything we want right here on earth
as I said some of these technologies
here's one again we're not talking about
in the future this year this latest crop
year in Africa farmers found that using
the same type of cotton that's been
grown here for several years that it has
an insect resistant gene built into it
that this so called bt cotton grown in
africa has doubled or more than doubled
their yields of cotton on their farms
and there's no reason that they cannot
get again doublings of yields with other
biotech crops as well well we don't even
need doublings in order to ultimately
feed the future of the world the book is
called bio evolution how the technology
is changing our world Michael fomento is
the author also associated with the
Hudson Institute thanks for joining us
on this Thanksgiving morning my pleasure
thank you